dans notre époque qui caractérisée par
le fait que tout est permis vous pouvez
dire aujourd'hui n'importe quoi sur
n'importe qui l'indiscrétion non
seulement permis mais l'indiscrétion est
devenue le vertu
alors on va parler là aussi une
constante de vos livres c'est
l'érotisme la sexualité et ce qui est
tout à fait curieux c'est que
il semble que le romancier que vous êtes
ne s'intéresse pas ne s'intéresse moins
à l'acte charnel que vous raconter
rarement que ce qui se passe avant ou
après alors ce qui se passe avant c'est
peut-être moi-même la séduction que je
dirais que l'excitation l'excitation de
l'excitation et puis après l'acte
charnel vous intéressez beaucoup à ce
qui est je ne sais pas le la séparation
la mélancolie etc ce que je me trompe ou
[Musique]
non vous n'êtes vous ne vous trompez pas
surtout dans dans le fait que
certainement il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'érotisme dans tous les romans que j'ai
écrit je me rappelle même quand je
disais avant dernière rire de rubriques
que j'ai reçu une lettre qui m'a fait
beaucoup de plaisir d'une lectrice qui
m'a écrit c'est pas possible de vous
lire parce que c'est seulement le
sexement le sexement le sexe j'ai pensé
que j'ai enfin je vais lire un dissident
de lynx et je me reposerai de cette de
cette obsession sexuelle occidentale
alors
Rihanna bien sûr mais en même temps vous
savez
l'érotisme aujourd'hui dans notre époque
qui caractérisée par le fait que tout
est permis vous pouvez dire aujourd'hui
n'importe quoi sur n'importe qui
l'indiscrétion non seulement permis mais
l'indiscrétion est devenue le vertu
c'est-à-dire dans n'importe quel livre
n'importe qui vous raconte n'importe
quel intimité n'est-ce pas ça nous
vivons dans une époque quand l'intimité
qui a dit était une valeur n'est plus
une valeur on dévalorise complètement
l'intimité c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce que
c'est la personnalité humaine sans
l'intimité sans sa vie privée au moment
quand la vie privée n'est plus la vie
privée la personnalité humaine c'est
évapore alors nous vivons un peu ce
moment-là donc cette grande
invasion de la sexualité de l'érotisme
dans la littérature je dois dire que je
suis j'ai quelques réserves ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui m'a qui m'a enchante
qui
m'enchante sans sans aucune réserve
malgré cela je suis bien sûr très attiré
par les situations érotiques mais
seulement dans la mesure où cette
situation érotique me dit quelque chose
en plus c'est donc seulement dans la
mesure où cette situation érotique est
révélatrice c'est tout d'un coup vous
avez dit que l'acte charnel n'est pas si
souvent traité dans mes livres c'est pas
tout à fait vrai je crois que on peut
même faire toute une anthologie des coït
très intéressant qui sont là-bas mais
c'est coïtes ces actes d'amour sont
toujours une révélation inattendue ou
bien d'une situation par exemple des
rapports des forces entre la femme et
l'homme ou bien de caractère
de personnages par exemple dans le
dernier roman il y a un acte d'amour
entre la personne
Sabina est France
tout d'un coup sa Béna regarde n'est-ce
pas en faisant l'amour avec lui elle a
l'impression que cette grande tombe
plein de muscles sont en fin de compte
une immense chiot qui tient qui s'arrête
parce que cet homme qui a cette attitude
disons féministe
à l'égard de la femme c'est à dire
adorateur de la femme même à dans l'acte
d'amour
un caractère tellement non viril que
tout d'un coup cette Sabina d'emblée
dans un dans un moment de de
d'éclairage lucide comprend que
c'est pas possible
continuer avec lui
[Musique]